welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Captain America's Civil War
clashed the man in the suit against the
man from the bottle what was in that
bottle the film mixes MCU fanservice
with an interesting deeper meaning that
isn't discussed enough secrets only
discoverable in a true frame-by-frame
analysis since you can see my face I may
look a bit spent here in the blue
dungeon mark 2 but trust me I know film
opens in Siberia 1991 the Hydra soldier
punches in the code 178 to 6 which on a
touchpad what translate to one standing
is there can be only one of that legend
so the Karpov is the winter soldiers
handler in the comics here he activates
Bucky with the trigger words boy spit
[ __ ]
daddy's actually run for the shiny on
the Roger I did it was a boy far gone
now it has been believed that 17 and
homecoming could have been teases for
spider-man homecoming releasing in 2017
but the screenwriters denied it suggests
that the words just sounded melodic and
menacing and Russian but ending on
freight car that can't be random because
a freight car was Bucky's last tactile
connection to cap before plunging into
hydras clutches Sputnik was Bucky's
trigger word in the comics and it was a
working title of this film
Bucky's cool music sting returns from
Winter Soldier
[Music]
now reportedly composer henry jackman
got the sound vive remix scene Bucky
screen from his fall and capped one but
that is a misconception Jackman said in
a 2014 interview that he recorded
himself screaming and processed the hell
out of it to evoke the sound of a
torture victim trapped inside machinery
same awesome idea just not literally
Bucky's voice our first shot of cap
shows and looking into the daylight a
contrast with his final shot in shadow
now this being a cat movie he has more
of an edge in the team cat versus team
Iron Man debate that has continued for
years but caps dissent in this film to
me underlies it's true message that in a
civil war there are no winners to win
one of these you must defeat your own
family that's not a victory still one
Avenger I think does win the moral
argument we'll find out who later their
mission is to stop crossbones Brock
rumlow returning from Winter Soldier his
arm attachments later return to the MCU
as scavenged parts in tombs crew in
spider-man homecoming Falcons new drone
is called red wing named after the bird
friend that he communicates with in the
comics he and Natasha chased down
crossbones agents don't you want to left
oh you did there Natasha given salmon on
your left
rumlow throws off cap by mentioning
Bucky cap still walking off later I'm
mostly luck you all said now is a 16
year old kid again in Brooklyn this is
how cap knows that just mentioning Bucky
will distract his younger self an
in-game Bucky Tony Stark shares a barf
memory at MIT
[Music]
Maria's song is an inspiration for
Toni's September grant to these MIT
students and in this memory she tells
Tony wake up say goodbye to your father
Tony mentioned this long time regret all
the way back in the first Ironman during
a press conference you were gonna show
you bud again I never could say goodbye
to my father this Bartek we later
learned was invented by Quentin Beck
who's standing just off stage in this
moment and it was later used by T
Mysterio to screw with Peter Parker's
mind Tony mentions here that the tech
works by hijacking the hippocampus which
explains how Peter was so fooled by
projections that were just inches away
from him they're just not Holograms
they're literally inside your brain
I've also speculated among the
recipients of Tony's grant could be riri
Williams MIT student and start follower
ironheart in the comics who is my pick
for the next Ironman please Tony
challenges all two and to Cooper
connection nods to his future good
tinkering giving Peter Parker his
literal frames in the future and his bad
past tinkering breaking eggs to invent
Ultron
everybody has to break anything clearly
you've never made an omelet he beat me
by one second Jim rash is one of the
Russos many community cameos along with
Danny Pudi and Winter Soldier and Ken
Jong an event to call Brown an endgame
his project is essentially the exploding
meat
Oh Tony had to deal with an Iron Man 3
with extremists which is like Tony
dismisses it Tony's confronted by a
grieving mother Miriam Spencer alfre
woodard who also played Mariah Dillard
and Luke Cage she's based on Miriam
sharp in the comics who lost her son
Damien in the mutant explosion that
killed six hundred people and sparked
the civil war framed on cab's desk this
is old monkey on a unicycle sketch that
he didn't cap one one is room she has
pinned up pictures of who I assume is a
young Petro RIT
directly beneath a globe with the
continent of Africa turned to face them
as they're discussing what they did
Nigeria so I guess we can just call this
one his guilt corner good old Ross
returns now Secretary of State five
years ago I had a heart attack
I found something 40 years in the Army
and never taught me perspective so
that's what they're calling juicing now
check out my Hulk breakdown for the Ross
Red Hulk theory there's seating
arrangement at the table parallels their
future ending of infinity war
those on the right dust those on the
left here survived and Tony's sitting
away from him just like how he's away
from the other it's when the snap
happens all right let's do a death down
on Rossi slideshow here New York 74
civilian casualties
that's deaths plus major injuries
project insight 23 sokovia 177 Lagos 26
that's a combined total of 300 that is
people pocket change it should be
proudly kept it so low compared three
hundred to the several thousand
worldwide we're currently losing every
day what do I know the response to all
this is the sokovia accords based on the
superhero Registration Act in the civil
war comics which forced superhumans to
reveal and register themselves helmet to
Zemo tracks down Karpov thanks dude
Natasha
leaking all of hydras files online and
Winter Soldier interestingly here's
Warrender you sure you're ready for the
world to see you as you really are
are you it turns out Nats action gave
their enemies a weapon that they could
use against them Zemo drowns Karpov in a
sink with a rim lower than his mouth yes
Peter Berger would say the thing is not
obey the laws of physics and all vision
bums us out with his go-to style
causality equation our very strength
invites challenge challenge incites
conflict conflict breeds catastrophe
he's extending the pattern Thor brought
up in Avengers your work with the
tesseract is what drew Loki to it and
his allies it is a signal to all the
realms of the earth is ready for a
higher form of war and Rohde welcomes
Mitch into their side boom yeah finally
guy switched his dumb catchphrase drop
it at his feet I'm like boom you looking
for this
start tells him about Miriam's son we
drop the building on him while we were
kicking this rings with cap especially
since these same phrasing was just used
by his most recent heroics created demon
on the funeral Peggy Carter there has
been some fun post endgame debate over
whether old cap could be an attendance
here maybe even that silver haired
pallbearer set photo show it's a
different actor and while the
screenwriters keep refuting their own
time travel logic to keep this idea live
the accepted Canon from the directors in
the studio insist old cap lifts is like
an alternate branch history trust me it
just makes more sense that way cap
learns that Sharon progressive Hall is
sharing corridor Peggy's great nice even
if everyone is telling you that
something wrong is something right even
if the whole world is telling you to
move it is your duty to plant yourself
like a tree look them in the eye and say
no you move this speech was actually
paraphrase from cat's words to Peter
Parker in the Civil War comics and which
Peter Parker starts on teamironman but
switches to team cap as well see
throughout this film characters will
tell cap to move but he never yields
wolf captain not moving this kind of a
cap thing can you see them no but before
you continue a reminder that new rock
stars has been struggling to keep these
breakdowns coming out to you due to
YouTube screwing us over during its
pandemic and delays with some small
business loans and you may have noticed
more saltiness than normal for me on
social media but I am trying to chill
out a bit now that we are partnering
with another small business which is
just trying to help get hand sanitizer
out in the world sanitize and chill
sanitize and show combines
hospital-grade ethanol based hand
sanitizer with CBD c meetings great it
helps me with my inflammation you can
dress this stuff we've been working very
closely with the manufacturer and
medical professionals to make sure it
meets the highest level of guidelines
there's no THC in the stuff so you're
not gonna get high but your hands will
get clean and it's the color green
because there's a lot of aloe vera in
there which keeps your hand smooth each
bottle has 100 milligrams of CBD an
alcohol content is 70% that's even
higher than the sixty percent of the CDC
recommends for in activating these
viruses and it's stronger than those
other brands that are way too hard to
find on shelves anyway now there's a
limited supply of 2,500 bottles because
of the small side
this company were working with in the
quality of this product so if you can I
would go for the multi bottle bundle
packs because they are seriously
discounted but we're gonna throw in
another discount there for you if you're
looking for hand sanitizer if you want
to help us act now go to bitly calm
slash in our chill and use the code new
rock stars tenets check out for ten
percent off your order
Natasha tells cap staying together is
more important and how we stay together
these words are framed as naive in this
moment cap is stubbornly heating the
advice of a dead woman maybe even
apocryphal advice because Sharon's one
quoting in we know she loves lying over
the advice of his fellow soldier being a
man out of time has been caps power but
here in this movie becomes his curse at
the UN in Vienna to chala chats with his
dad again dodo resume comes Helena Kazan
buuza come Gallagher we pretty been yeah
content spoken language is based on
forgive my pronunciation Xhosa it's a
South African dialect spoken by Nelson
Mandela to chacas rain is a critical
clue later when a similar one shows up
around kill mongers neck we know that
he's part of this royal lineage bomb
kills to taka to Talam mourns in my
culture did it's not the end you reach
out with both hands and bust it sick MIT
they lead you into the green belt where
could the round forever
char let's describe what we later find
out is the ancestral plane bust is the
Panther goddess of what kind of
mythology who comes up in that movie's
prologue a Wadi a shaman received a
vision from the Pentagon is bust
Bucky hides out in Bucharest Romania
which interestingly is one of the
outpost fury work that captain Marble
Belfast Bucharest Belgrade Budapest I
like to be a second Megamind
alliteration isn't writing perhaps fury
was helping Bucky's stay off the grid
after the events of Winter Soldier bucky
test plumes for ripeness this winter
soldier arm meaning this guy has enough
sensitivity in that thing that it
probably hurts like hell when Tony later
blasts it off cap helps him escape
covering the grenade with his shield
first time this guy's dived on a grenade
Bucky leaps to the lower roof and notice
that we followed this brave wire
stuntman all the way down until notice
the camera shakes downward asking the
cut where that stunt man now without the
wire lands on the ledge clever
camerawork there then a great
introduction
lucky sees black panther's feet-first
but he didn't hear him because while his
footsteps work abdul kalam p two
challahs shock-absorbing vibranium suit
made his footsteps silent this exciting
chase ends with rody arresting all of
them major missed opportunity for a boom
his war machine armor is now marked
three following the mark two iron
Patriot armor from Iron Man 3 in the
marked one armor from Iron Man 2 notice
how his armor has tallied Ultron's
century heads on it for his skills in
sokovia and its name is printed on it
which you know wasn't ever a secret but
now that the superhero registration is
under debate any name tag is a statement
vision makes wanted to stay in the
kitchen ok Bucky gets detained in the
cellmark d23 and not to footage for this
movie being shown early at Disney's d23
conference Tony and agent Everett Ross
confiscate caps shield technically it's
the government's little foreshadowing of
Tony reclaiming his father's invention
later as shield doesn't belong to you
Tony tries to appeal to caps World War
two history with the pins FDR used to
sign the lend-lease bill which ended the
us's neutrality policy but Tony doesn't
know that timeline of events led to this
unfrozen Capeman soldier being stuck in
a time that scares and confuses him if I
see a situation pointed South I can't
ignore cap describes this encompassed
headings evoking his North Star Peggy
Carter cap snaps at tony's protection of
Wanda recalling his debate with fury and
Winter Soldier I holding a gun to
everyone on earth - calling it
protection and he growls at Tony Tony
every time I go in his blog rant moment
age of Ultron every time someone tries
to win a war before it starts innocent
people die every time every time
Zemo activates Bucky who fights Natasha
she's calling back their fight and
Winter Soldier but also the time he's
shot through her to kill a target yeah
calf takes Bucky to the gun show and
saves him from the water we returning
the favor from Winter Soldier and we see
the safehouse moment from the in man
post credits scene and Bucky reveals cuz
I'm not the only one or soldier
boom we learned that Bucky was one out
of six winter soldiers the same number
as the og Avengers see both cap and
Bucky were soldiers out of their times
heme DUP with five other freaks to fight
wars that weren't theirs in Queens Tony
meets Aunt May and Peter Parker showing
that Tony learned nothing from Miriam
about putting kids in danger we get
spider-man out when you can do the
things that I can but you don't
and then the bad things happen they
happen look at you so you're basically
saying with great power comes great
responsibility
yeah yeah Wanda uses her mind stone to
ride powers to hijack visions mind stone
manipulating this body density to free
Clint and then sink him to health leave
them on to the best airport ever now
notice cap removed the Avengers logo
from his shoulder here yes a minute when
he said he broke up the set Q spider-man
[Music]
boom spider-man suits I pieces had
binocular lenses that narrow and widen
like a camera lens allowing Peter to
emote through his eyes characterizing
him when he has his mask on it's one of
the many reasons this third live-action
spider-man was the charm this airport
includes the Bluth family stair car from
Arrested Development an awed by the roof
says to their directing work on the
sitcom a blue man shows up in the
collectors Walt infinity war the full
lineups charge compared to the Civil War
lineup splash page in the comics there
are a ton of characters marvel left out
from this film but check out the
upcoming episode of the big question
where we figure out which teams these
sideline characters would have been on
cap pins Peter where you from
please Brooklyn cats smile here is him
remembering a similar exchange with dr.
Earth's kind where are you from Queens
so that is the little guy from actually
Brooklyn Hawkeye and it man partner up
recreating the image from Avengers 223
Scott shrinking down through the gaps of
Tony's armor is what inspires Tony to
finally upgrade to the seamless nanotech
armor and infinity war and an end game
they use this past loophole do shrink
inside Tony's 2012 armor Hawkeye needs
black panther we haven't met yet
I'm good I don't care but the child will
be much sweeter and a call back an end
game wait
DB meter takes down giant Scott by using
luke skywalker's tow cable move from the
Empire Strikes Back and I just got to
point out the great look of fear that
Robert Downey jr. gives when he thinks
Peter is seriously hurt that fear will
definitely come back for him an infinity
war roadie uses the sonic blast the same
tech on these stark designs sonic cannon
used on Hulk and later shows up on the
drones apart from home Tony actually
learns the power of discrete drones here
in this battle when Sam bops some with
Red Wing notice that Tony was going to
snare Falcon with this projectile net
vision mrs. salmon disables Rhodey music
terrifyingly cuts out and whoops
Zemo weirdly calls a hotel so they find
the body of dr. Broussard a cameo by
co-director Joe Russo who came using all
these movies but why would seem oh call
attention to his deception well the
reason is that this tells us that he
wanted Stark to discover his meddling in
order to were both Tony and captain so
that he could drop the truth bomb on
them in the same room Tony arrives at
the raft in the comics the raft is a
superhero prison near Rikers but this
version replaces prison 42 from the
civil war comics place where Tony read
Richardson Hank Pym kept superhumans in
the negative zone on the wall here is
r3l 8 or real 8 for Tony now having to
relate to his rivals or maybe it's just
room 3 level 8 whatever plant welcomes
them when he's often called a futurist
in the comics and yeah his future
doomsday vision has defined him since
Ultron but also Robert Downey jr.
released an album called the futurist in
the early 2000s in Siberia Bucky raids a
gun drawer labeled Romanov these are
Nats guns and the two friends remember
old times what was really beginning to
Loras you called your damn plane Dottie
Underwood was one of Peggy Carter's
enemies an agent Carter
Tony joins cap and Bucky but hands up
trapped into seeing the footage of Bucky
killing his parents footage ends with
Bucky shooting out the camera from
Starks point of view this recalls the
moment Bucky shot directly at his face
earlier Bucky is also emotional here he
and cap we're friends with Howard Stark
back in the day
Bucky confirms this guilt later in the
fight
one does that Bucky no repulsors
activated which is why cap could hold
him back totally just wanted to take a
raw swing Kat reveals that he knew to
zola showed him a flash of the
assassination headline in Winter Soldier
from that he deduced hydras involvement
Tony
eyeballs the missile at Bucky if you
think about Obadiah Stane had to do the
same thing in Ironman one after Tony
disabled his targeting system Tony has
held the moral high ground for most of
this film but here he loses his sense of
reason just like his old foes did Bucky
nearly claws out Tony's heart but Tony's
mark 46 armor is equipped with the
features of past suit so he focuses all
the energy into his chest reactor the
main feature of the mark 17 heartbreaker
from Iron Man 3 and he blasts off
Bucky's arm wait what is this phase 2
nope just kidding we are done with that
[ __ ] Tony also has the repulsor our
backhand from the arc 40 shotgun armor
that he used against Killian the most
interesting is this new feature in
Elijah's fight pattern scanning he's
gonna algorithm that allows them to
predict caps moves and mirror them now
back with that black widow trailer came
out look Lois Lee a taskmasters I pieced
he had a HUD with a similar analysis
going on in there that movie is gonna
take place right after these events so
it's taskmaster using Tony's fight
analysis tech well that there's another
video cap repeats his big line yeah I
know he and Tony restaged the classic
Civil War part 7 cover cap rips off
Tony's mass but instead of going to the
face he goes for the reactor ripping up
the mask was a merciful move to help
Tony breathe after a suit would have
been disabled just like Tony did to help
Rhodey breathe Zemo listens to his dead
wife's voice mail these messages were
actually recorded by Anthony Russo's
wife and T'Challa rest him leaving Zemo
to return in the upcoming Falcon Winter
Soldier where he will apparently Don his
comic accurate purple mask vision holds
a rook chess piece what you think about
it is the one piece on the board that
represents an inanimate object instead
of a person because he is a walking box
of scraps Stan Lee cameos as a FedEx
delivery guy are you Tony dank and cats
littered leaves Tony with this flip
phone which Tony will later use an
infinity war to call him back and the
post-credits scenes tease the future
Bucky goes back
nice in Wakanda Peter tells it made that
he fought a Steve from Brooklyn and his
huge friend before lighting up his
Spidey signal but in the film the final
image shows cap rescuing Sam and the
others from the raft he was once in the
light now he's in darkness his
stars-and-stripes identity left behind
him now he's the country list Nomad
identity and his return in fin a war is
the same exact shot a parallel step from
the shadows see neither Tony nor cap
oneness Civil War neither changed the
other's mind both of them are weaker
than when they started both of them hurt
their friends because of their
stubbornness and blindness to reason cat
because of his dead girlfriend Tony
because of his dead mommy and that
division will cause both of these guys
to end and then they were knocked on
their asses looking back on this film
the one hero to maintain the moral high
ground is the one who fought on both
teams Natasha Romanov while tramatic
reveals lead to mistakes by the others
Matt lives with the red in her ledger
all day she bounces when it gets too
personal and I cannot wait to see her
next move from here in the Black Widow
movie which will be set directly after
this the smartest point anyone makes in
this debate the point that ends up being
the truest and infinity war an endgame
was Natasha's ignored hope staying
together is more important than how we
stay together and because they didn't
listen to her that is how the adventures
will lose together will lose and we'll
do that together too
boom who do you think won the Civil War
you can join our future infinity Saga
watch longze by joining our discord i've
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
new rock stars follow me EDA vos follow
me rock stars and subscribe for our next
MCU rewatched as we try to figure out
which hand is making dr. strange make
that face
[Music]